[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it actually took the ride we wrapped it
right around the front gate so when
everyone arrives first thing they see is
this ride because one of those wow
moments walk in you look up in the hill
just gets bigger and bigger as your
project
[Music]
you get on the ride you're strapped in
boom and you move forward that's it
you're riding this ride
[Music]
this is some massive lift Hill 325 feet
tall against 60 SEC's until you get to
the top there's a lot of things going
through your mind like should I be doing
this I wonder what it's like we call
that the moment of regret so when you
get up to the top most of the people are
looking straight ahead I think we're
gonna be scared they've been craving
that moment as soon as you get over that
crest
it looks like the track disappears and
that's the moment when you start to go
into freefall and they just stream all
the way down the hill
after the drop you don't want to take
away that speed and all of that inertia
so you go in and out of those church so
smoothly then again along the ride we
need to throw in a lot of surprises all
of it is calculated to just give that
illusion of danger what was with that
one beam did they forget about that it
almost seemed like a mistake do you
remember when we tucked under the fridge
when you're up at 180 feet looking down
at it that's the moment where you think
am I gonna make it through that
some people to conduct because it's just
so tight the payoff in the end are three
consecutive bills with airtime where you
lift right off at the seat and you float
the hill intensity actually greases when
you come back into the station
at the end of the ride
people were high-fiving and clapping
everyone says that ride never let up and
they're just so excited to get back on
and do it again
[Applause]